The moon has a lot of looks.
And each one happens for a reason.
It takes the moon about 29 and a half days
to orbit around the Earth.
And during this time, the sun illuminates
the moon from varying angles which creates
a shadow effect that we see here on Earth.
At the start of each lunar cycle, the moon
is between the earth and the sun.
This is called a “New Moon”.
The side of the moon visible from Earth is
not illuminated and therefore we can’t see
it.
As the angle between the Moon and the Sun
increases, so does the amount of moon we’re
able to see.
After the new moon, it enters the waxing crescent
phase where we can see 1 to 49% of the moon.
When it reaches 50% illumination, it becomes
a first quarter moon, which is kinda confusing
but we’ll roll with it.
Next is the waxing Gibbous phase, which means
we can see about half to almost all of the
moon.
And finally… we get to see the big cheese.
We get one glorious night of full moon and
then the illumination starts to fade.
After a full moon, we see the waning phase
which is the opposite of waxing.
The moon follows the same illumination pattern
just flipped with the final phase being the
waning crescent.
Then it starts all over again with the new
moon!
The way you see the moon depends on where
you are on the globe.
If you’re in the Northern Hemisphere, a
waxing moon will be illuminated on the right
side while a waning moon will be illuminated
on the left.
It’s the opposite in the Southern Hemisphere.
So now you know, the next time you see a waxing
moon, a full moon is right around corner.
You can catch new episodes of Space Crafts
every Wednesday!
In this episode, we'll explain what happens
when the Sun explodes and the potential fallout
for Earth.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe!